hey everyone I'm grin and I'm the tech
lead at
cabin cabin is a group of internet
friends building a network city of
modern Villages and that's kind of a
long sentence it's got a lot to it so
let's go piece by piece um when I say A
group of internet friends I actually
mean a pretty large group we have 4,200
community members and 355 citizens which
is a yearly paid membership and we also
have 23 locations around the world where
cabin members gather and
live all right what's a network City a
network city is kind of like a physical
City in that it's physical but it's also
distributed across space and onto the
internet um it's we think of a city less
as one spot and more like the context
for your day-to-day living it's where
you work it's where you meet your
friends it's where your kids go to
school so unlike a state we're not
looking for diplomatic recognition but
we do want to get to the point where
somebody could say I live in cabin and
really mean
it all right last part what's a modern
Village that's our shortest way of
talking about the two parts of our ethos
so Village is about Community nature
about living together and modern is
about embracing technology and
Innovation so this this is what the
people look like at cabin these are the
people who've come to our community
calls whove lived with us um and who are
part of the cabin community and I can
also show you the places in Cabin these
are locations that are all around the
world we have 23 of them including some
here in Europe and they're all beautiful
locations with high-speed internet and
nature out the front door and they're
all open to cabin
members a bit of History cabin's been
around for a couple years and over time
we've done several dozen Gatherings of
different types across different scales
and durations anything from side events
at conferences to weeklong and
month-long residencies all the way up to
long-term co- living and these
experiments have reinforced to us that
you can't create a city top down you has
to evolve from something smaller and
simpler than itself you have to grow it
kind of like a garden I think this tweet
really sums it up
well and you know rich I have good news
for you which is that we are working on
this with a program we call supper clubs
it's exactly what it sounds like you get
together with some interesting people
you cook a meal together you talk about
things you like you snap some selfies
for social media and cabin picks up the
bill there's supper clubs all over it's
the easiest way to connect with cabin
and I'll tell you guys later how to get
involved with
one all right we did the physical part
but cabin's also a network City and we
build with code not just wood so over
time we've built out a way for the cabin
Community to get in touch online it's
several components working together
these components I think exist across
all online offline communities and they
look a little different depending on
what your community is so I'll show you
what ours look like
so the census this is where you start
your identity in the cabin online World
anyone can create a profile in the
census and start to build your
reputation within the
community over time the census collects
stamps the same way that your laptop
gathers stickers or a Boy Scout you know
earns marit badges these stamps are your
history of participation within cabin
and we've given out thousands of these
for people who come to community calls
people who come to events like this
people who co- with
us the city directory is a list of those
locations that I showed you earlier it's
what we consider within city limits for
cabin it's also an open token curated
registry any citizen can add locations
to the census and anyone with tokens can
vote on which location they like best so
locations with more votes move to the
top of the list which provides
information for people who want to stay
there and also useful feedback for the
hosts at these
locations citizenship I've said citizen
a couple times now citizenship is our
subscription membership to cabin for 0 2
eth a year you get access to the city
directory and to our annual Gathering to
partnership perks to our merch store you
also get a custom citizen card kind of
like this with a chip in it that gives
you access to
cabin um citizenship works on a web of
trust model so you have to know a
citizen who will Rouch for you to let
you in um but if you want to join you
can find me or there's several other
citizens here today who can vouch for
you finally the network pulse this is
our newest thing and we're just starting
working on this now uh this might look a
little bit like what just showed you 10
minutes ago ours is less of his
dashboard and more of like the bulletin
board in the Town Square it's one
central place where you can come and see
what's going on in cabin and also what's
about to happen so there might be
locations for people getting together
and there also might be places where
they want to get together next either
for a Meetup or to start a new cabin
node but it's not just information from
within the cabin app it's also citizens
and members activity all across the
internet so you can see there's a Strava
challenge that people are competing in
there's blog posts from mirror and
substack there's nft mints there's salsa
nights any social and onchain activity
from all of the members of cabin all
pulled together in one
place we think that this is how the
hybrid communities in our space will
bridge the gap between physical and
digital and we've built this for us but
we're also building it for you
everything you see here the city
directory the census the citizenship the
stamps we also have uh roles we have a
whole booking flow a bunch of stuff I
don't have time to show in this talk all
of that comes from the years of
experience that we have running these
events and we want to offer this to
everyone here these uh Primitives like I
said exist in all hybrid communities and
they won't won't look exactly like ours
ours are pretty custom to us but the
underlying principles are the same so if
you're interested in something like this
for your network City come find
me so how to get in touch with
us if you're interested in IRL
connection I want you to go to a supper
club you know don't be the guy from the
Tweet if you're if you wanna if you're
serious about Network States and if
you're here I can tell you are serious
then a local dinner if is the best way
to get started so if you go to cabin.
city/ Club you can sign up for one
there's probably one near you and cabin.
City also has our community Forum our
Discord our socials other ways to
connect with us
online or if you want to talk more Tech
if that caught more your eye you can
connect with me
directly once again my name is grin I'm
the tech lead at cabin before cabin I
was a founder of several other companies
kind of adjacent to the space like
library and Vibe camp and I'm at cabin
today because I want to build the city
that I want to live in not just for me
but for my friends for my family for my
tribe so come get in touch say hi go to
grin. if you want to reach out to me or
see me here later and uh I wanted to
show you guys this card I only have one
of these so I'm sorry I can't give one
to all of you but I'm going to toss this
out
to you right here so please take that um
pass it around pass it around to as many
people as you can I want everyone to see
it and then uh at 7 p.m. whoever's got
it please bring it to
me thank
you